a month ago the prime minister sent
millions of school students home
for a second time how many weeks are
there still to go
and what impact is it having on young
people
welcome to covid and the classroom
reopening schools must be our national
priority and the first sign of normality
beginning to return should be pupils
going back
to their classrooms
by february half term um pupils across
the uk will have missed out
on about half a year of normal schooling
we recognize day in day out on our
children's faces
when we see them on google classroom or
on microsoft teams
that desperation that they want to be
back at school
lots of people i think will be
scratching their heads and say how come
our schools are closed but our borders
are open
we do need a national long-term plan
to get us out of the educational swamp
because i worry that long after
coronavirus has gone we will have an
epidemic of educational poverty in our
country
[Music]
well last week we looked at the wider
issues caused by the school closures
on tonight's program we're going to be
focusing on the challenges
facing secondary age students with six
young people
at different stages of their school
careers you saw most of them there in
that opening video
and a very big welcome to all of you
well also with us tonight is taran
kapoor the chief executive of the dean
trust which runs a number
of secondary schools and a former
secondary school head teacher
of the year and a very warm welcome to
you too
so let's start our discussions tonight
with an aspect of a young person's
education which can easily be
underplayed
the benefits of spending time with their
peers
and for all the many different problems
associated with school closures and
homeschooling
one of the main concerns for parents is
the social effect
on their children a yougov poll for
ofsted
last month found when parents were asked
the main challenge for their children
that 38 said lack of contact with
classmates
that outweighed the lack of contact with
teachers at
35 percent and was significantly more
troubling to them
than the many difficulties of access to
the right device
for home learning well let's bring in
kieran in carlisle aged 17 who missed
taking gcses last year
and now in your first year of a levels
kira
and sick form is normally such a big
change isn't it
is it hard that you're not sharing this
formative time with your
your classmates and your friends
yeah it really is like it's very
different just being at home this is the
kind of time where you think
you're really socializing with everybody
it's a kind of a different aspect of
school
and it is it is different obviously you
can
see people on zooms but it's just not
really the same especially when in sixth
form you have
you freeze and you have your lunch times
and just
being with your peers who also share the
same interests you're doing the subjects
you really want to do
like it really influences you when
you're in school and it is very strange
not having that around you and
doing all your work by yourself and and
just being
like in the house alone
yes the house all the time it feels like
doesn't it for many of us
and do you find it difficult to get
motivated as well to stick with it
um at first i did i think i've got a bit
more used to it now but you definitely
have to be
very self-sufficient very self-motivated
you have your zooms that are scheduled
but there's a lot of work
that you're left to do for yourself in
your own time when you get
chunked so yeah i've kind of got into a
routine now so i'm kind of
trying to stick to the normal school day
so i'm trying to keep everything
you know in check and on time and
meeting my deadlines but it is difficult
to motivate yourself when you don't have
set lesson times and like the teachers
there to kind of give you that extra
push
yes it's all about trying to structure
yourself isn't it kira thank you for
that
and certainly that reliance on your
phone your laptop or your tablet
for your interaction as we all know is
not the same as a face-to-face
conversation and for secondary school
children there are some big decisions
that need to be made
how much harder is it then to do that
when your school is closed
what gcses you're going to do what a
levels you're going to do or for someone
like kira
the university applications that you've
got to start thinking about
so let's sort now to trey in north
london one of those
wrestling with some of those life
choices and trey you're
14 aren't you so that's what year nine
having to choose
your gcse options soon are you missing
chatting it over with your friends or
even your teachers
yes i'm really missing you know being at
school and being able to communicate
with the other students
and you know it's it's quite hard as
well that i've got my gcst's picking
them
right around the corner as well so it's
very you know it's quite a lot
and trey just very quickly and does the
day feel longer for you
um being at home did you did you get
homework on top before
so the days have actually been feeling a
lot quicker
and you know sometimes with homework and
school work sometimes i can still be on
the laptop doing
my work till about five o'clock six
o'clock so
yeah but definitely i think that these
have felt like they've been going a lot
quicker the fact i'm you know
only staying in one place in my house
indeed so
well trey thank you good luck with those
gcse choices of course as well
now one of the biggest issues has of
course been those missed exams
last year with the added stress of an
algorithm helping to decide grades
and approach subsequently if you
remember ditched this year
scotland and wales decided fairly early
on that pupils
would have missed too many lessons for
exams to go ahead
england has now followed but what impact
does
all of that have the uncertainty and the
problems last year certainly
well roman is in stockport let's come to
you now you're 15.
you had been due to set your gcses this
summer
has the uncertainty been difficult for
you and what does it do to your
motivation
yeah it's definitely hard to motivate
yourself when you don't know what
working towards um with uncertainty it's
hard to know
sort of why you're doing all these
online lessons and why you're working so
hard because it's not that traditional
format
and i think that does make it really
hard to motivate yourself to
go that extra mile in year one
how does your school manage home
learning are you online all day
or are you working mainly on your own
some lessons the more practical lessons
um are doing
setting us work and then just leaving us
to it and some
that are more um academic are guiding us
through things
um but we do have a structured 193 still
just like we would if we were at school
roman thank you very much indeed for
that yes it's all about trying to get
this structure in your own day isn't it
which is really difficult when there's
so many distractions around
uh well the question of the harm to
young people from the lockdown has been
causing concern for many senior
specialists in education
earlier this year ofsted's chief
inspector of schools in england
amanda spielman set out the case for why
schools should stay open
if possible she said children's lives
can't just be put on hold
while we wait for vaccination programs
to take effect and for waves of
infection to subside
we cannot follow young people's learning
or their wider development
well sadly soon after she made those
comments all schools were indeed closed
the cases of infections spreading too
rapidly to allow them to stay open
so how damaging is it being off for so
long let's talk now to
13 year old tina who's also in north
london in year nine
this is the second time you've all had
to do this isn't it tina
does it feel more normal this time have
you have you kind of got used to it
yeah i have got more used to it but i
think it's not a good thing
because this has become my normal just
sitting in front of a screen all day
and every day just seems very repetitive
and it's all a blur
it feels repetitive and do you find
space to work do you have
do you have distractions at home
um yeah definitely um my phone's right
next to me it's really hard to
discipline myself
and make sure i engage myself in the
lessons what's the bit you miss most do
you think about being
in school and around friends and
classmates
i think definitely talking to my friends
and that gives me motivation to
engage in lessons and work harder but
now that i don't have that
it's hard to um make sure i listen
and do all the work in time yes i think
you're spelling it out for many people
at your age you've got the distractions
of interactions haven't you
and if you don't have that and it's all
about school work it feels much more
stressful you know thank you very much
indeed for that
well experts in child health have been
stressing throughout that while it's
best
for the control of the virus more widely
that schools be closed the damage to
children
is clear the children young people under
20 makeup they're about 15 million
in our population they make up about 23
and a half percent of our population
and we have closed when we close schools
we close their lives
not to benefit them but to benefit the
rest of society
and in fact children and young people
when we close schools they
uh re-palm from that
well let's bring in taran kapoor then
who oversees ten schools
in northwest england wow we're talking
about huge numbers of young people
across the uk aren't we
15 million for whom this has an enormous
impact
what are you most worried about then is
it the bits as we've been hearing there
about missing out on social interactions
about seeing your friends
or are you more worried about the pure
education that people are missing
yeah there's a number of evening anna
there's a number of things i would say
first of all certainty for parents
can be stressful but uncertainty for
parents and for young people
is unbearable and the mental health
issues and well-being issues just
surfacing
each day in fact in school today one of
our secondary schools we had 70 phone
calls that were made this morning to our
children who
needed somebody to talk to somebody to
be kind to them
the joy of being in school is lost
and i've challenged all my head teachers
with
starting september which is almost to
reinvigorate
not the academic but everything else
that's good about school everything we
remember
about school and it isn't the lessons in
fact many children are sick of lessons
because that's all they've had and
parents must be when they hear that
phrase remote learning it must make
their hearts sing so
we're concentrating now trying to raise
our heads and not just our schools
outside many schools raise our heads
look at the power of it and say right we
know what's happening with the
um the pandemic but in september we
anticipate being back in
properly any after easter but i think
that'll be social distancing and bubbles
and children will get sent home and
brought back into school as they have
done
but september's a key day for me and is
there any specific year that you are
most worried about
well year 11 obviously because last year
was straightforward because they
completed most of the course and we had
evidence this year some of our year 11
who were year 10 last year
have missed nine months worth of work
and
the consultation took place last week
and 50 000 people
signed up to it including almost 25 000
young people and next week was supposed
to hear something about the plan
not having a plan is more stressful than
having us than having a plan that isn't
very good to be honest so
year 11 i'll be concerned about also
year 10 who have exams
next summer but actually if you think
about the year sevens they
didn't have any sort of celebration when
they were in year six
they almost have their leading
assemblies and shows
they started in year seven they've not
had a proper induction
and they don't know many people speaking
to one yesterday and he said sir
i love coming in school but i'd love for
the rest of school to be here as well
it's really sad that that is true isn't
it it's not being able to
say goodbye at the end of your education
it's not making friends at the start of
it
it's all it all is tricky uh mr kapoor
for a moment thank you very much indeed
uh well scotland has now announced the
date that younger pupils
can return all being well at least the
first three years of primary
but also those in older age ranges whose
practical work around exam years means
they need to be in such as art or music
so let's talk now to elpeda in leeds age
17 year 12 then
hoping to study medicine at university
and lpd you're finding it hard
to get the relevant experience is that
right
yeah because if we were at school we
would have done loads of clubs
club work and work experience and we
would have gone out and gone to
different
industries and workplaces to try out for
work experience however now it's all
virtual and
it's because virtual there's limited
places and harder to get into
and so it's a struggle to get involved
as much as you would like
you also started a new school didn't you
for sixth form this is not the easiest
way to bed in and make new friends
yeah it's been kind of crazy because we
started friendships
and we got kind of close but not to the
extent where we could talk
every day via online and so it's
we made close friends but then we
separated for a really long period of
time so it
gives hesitation on how it's going to be
when we go back
well peter thank you for that indeed uh
schools are still open of course
bear that in mind to those whose parents
are key workers or
they are deemed vulnerable and it is a
juggle certainly for teachers to do both
the online learning that they need to
set or be envisioned for for those at
home
and teach those in class or wherever
they're put
to stick to social distancing rules i
know some people we spoke to last week
have been
working in offices and a lot of children
also have a couple of days
at school and then a couple of days at
home however the school can
accommodate them so let's introduce
brooke now
age 13 so year 8 in southeast london
and brooke last lockdown you were at
home because you both your parents are
key workers this time you're now at home
which did you find better
um well neither of them was perfectly
ideal because most of my friends parents
aren't key workers
so i didn't really get to spend time
with many of my friends and stuff
but being at home and being at school
they're quite two
different uh surroundings because school
was quite loud and
the amount of people that were there
there weren't many but it was still
like there was still noise around but
being at home it's more quiet
and you've just got your family around
you and it's hard to talk to the people
that you don't see every single day that
is indeed true isn't it brooke for the
moment thank you very much
indeed well let's shift focus now and
while the social aspect of
education is fundamental to a young
person's well-being
school is also a vehicle for social and
economic advancement
each day of school education lost has a
cost to the young person involved
not just now but also for the future and
not just for themselves but for the
wider economy too
by the middle of this month children
will have lost half an academic year
that is five percent
of their total education in school
learning the world bank estimates that a
year's schooling increasing a person's
education on average by eight percent a
year for a nation like the uk
so based on the average yearly wage the
institute for fiscal studies
that that would mean a potential of 40
000 pounds lost
in income across a lifetime so even if
the government gives
additional support to help students the
catch-up learning we've heard about
the ifs suggests there would still be 90
billion pounds in lost lifetime earnings
but overall tax revenue is hard for
young children to compete right now when
they
are more concerned about qualifications
for themselves so
let's go back to akira then one of your
worries is that you face sitting
a levels next year having never sat
a major exam before that sounds
stressful
yeah it is a little bit daunting because
obviously we've done our mocks but we've
never done an official exam
and a level's a bit of a step up from
gcse
so it's it's a little bit scary to think
that we're going to go into our first
a level exam never having had the exam
experience
yet and um at the moment as well we
can't really have a level mocks
as we're at home so we're missing out on
that aspect as well
kira thank you it is prompting some
people to think about a rethink about
exams but not for this program perhaps
we'll
delve into that in more detail in the
months to come
so we'll catch up learning then catch on
how would you feel about
first of all teaching yourself at home
for some months several months
and then having to make up law school
work in the summer holidays when perhaps
you can actually see your friends
and that's where your priority might be
well trey is one of those where
all the homework sent home as we heard
earlier on top of the homeschooling
left some students working sometimes
until five or six o'clock at night you
said that earlier didn't you trey
and do you fancy catching up then do you
feel you've learnt as much at home
as you would have done in class
no i don't think we've you know learnt
as much as
we have at home you know if we were at
school obviously as we're engaging more
you know and it's more motivated in
class we would have been able to learn
more
and you know at home sometimes it's like
you know as you're at home and on the
computer you know it's
like you don't really sometimes it's
like i feel like i don't i can't always
listen all the time and sometimes you
know i might feel a bit tired and i'm
not as engaged
as i am yeah i i hear you
and i think of my own children as you
say that out loud i have to say
trey thank you very much indeed um it is
important to point out that there is a
slightly different roadmap for schools
reopening in
the different parts of the different
nations of the uk
in england all schools will continue
with remote learning until march the 8th
at the earliest in wales the earliest
possible date for an end to remote
learning is the 22nd of february
in scotland we've mentioned already the
government there is looking
at a possible phased return to school
also
from the 22nd of february while in
northern ireland remote learning will
continue
until at least the 5th of march although
special schools do
remain open so how will it feel going
back then let's return to hina
and how are you feeling about it hina
will it be nerve-wracking for you do you
think returning to school
yeah i think it definitely will because
i haven't
socially interacted with people in so
long face to face
so i'm nervous about how it's going to
be but i'm mainly excited because after
being home from
for so long i just can't wait to go back
to school
do you find though that you've become a
bit of a homebody and you spend most of
your time
indoors yeah definitely
since we're at home i don't really want
to leave the house anymore
because i don't feel comfortable leaving
the house anymore i'm just not used to
it
we wish you the very best of luck with
that and you know broaching the big
outside i think
many of us feel the same way i have to
say well we heard the prime minister say
that schools are
both safe and vectors of transmission
the concern being that they
could take the virus home the students
that is and then you would get
household infection to parents or beyond
certainly that is on the mind of brooke
who has lots of distractions
at home like her little brother but also
worried about the impact of possibly
spreading the virus to
members of her family her grandad has
a heart condition um and this is this is
tricky isn't it because you know that
you're going to school and you're
mingling
with lots of people did you have a
concern then about being at school
before christmas and
and possibly spreading it amongst the
family
yeah i definitely did because um both my
parents are key workers and my brother's
autistic
so say if he was to get coronavirus or
what if my mom
or one of my parents were to kick
coronavirus then
they wouldn't be able to do their jobs
anymore and my brother wouldn't have the
normal routine that he's really used to
and it would just make everything off
balance
yes it is a real concern so let's let's
gauge how you all feel about that then
i'm going to ask you to put your hands
up for your answer
so the question is if you could would
you go back to school tomorrow
or would you prefer to see the virus
figures come down first
hands up first of all for back tomorrow
fascinating and hands up then until the
figures come down
there you are well that's a resounding
isn't it that is another big factor
in all of this the awareness of young
people to the dangers
of this virus so let's bring in taran
kapoor again and your job
certainly is to make children feel safe
amid the pandemic and
try to catch up and fill all those holes
of lost education
yeah i tend to agree with the vote i
have to say
that's the first thing secondly i'll be
inspired by the young people who've been
on tonight remember it's a mixed economy
and we have many families across the
country and many in our schools where
they have a device at home but they may
have three children
and we are offering live lessons so only
one of them can actually access the live
lesson at a time so
whatever we do live lessons and remote
learning could never be as good as being
in school
saying that i don't think the government
can get it wrong again i think they have
to
choose the time to allow the secondary
schools to come back so
we're not going back out again because
that's the biggest frustration
obviously vaccinating the staff would be
the right things to do
having a big decision in the next week
to advance examinations would be
good because these the staff are
stressed about that as well
there's a lot of catch up to do but i
think going back to my original point
if the children come back to a school
that's got
a bit of joy in it and they absolutely
love being back in
they'll quickly start to catch up and i
think
ofsted and other bodies like that need
to give us a bit of space so we can
actually start to recoup
recuperate repair and start to move
forward
it's fairly simple it's common sense but
you know we're ready for it um
the young people are right we have to go
back at the right time
and then just get on with it become a
normal school there's too many phrases
that we use now which
will be part of their history
unfortunately so just very quickly
are you quite relieved that the exams
for this year are not gonna are not
gonna happen even though you'll have to
do teacher assessments presumably
well that's not exactly the case because
one of the suggestions is that
there would be some form of examination
at the end of year 11
and the euro levels don't know anything
about that yet because it hasn't been
announced but we've certainly been
briefed that there may be something at
the end but we don't know at what point
um and it may be there just to help us
make our decision because we've not had
the children in school for long you know
but until we know that and we have
certainty we don't want to go out to our
families and say
this is what's going to happen and can
you imagine year 11 is coming back
and they don't know if they're doing
examinations they don't know how they're
going to get the grades
the deep motivation would be incredible
you know the teachers are already
stressed without having to work with
young people who are thinking why am i
here
we tried to speak to the special adviser
of the education secretary to find out
about exams before we came on he didn't
answer they should have done shouldn't
they they could have clarified whether
or not you're having any
and we could all learn that a quick
thought then from from roman
what are you most looking forward to
when you go back
i think just that sense of normality
structure again
um the way that it is at the moment that
is just so
uncertain day to day that it can be
really stressful for us
i think that if we can get back into
school and it's safe to get
back into school that's a step in the
right direction and a step towards
regaining a sense of
structure for everybody yes indeed it's
interesting that you all focus on being
safe when you go back that is
that is interesting for us certainly and
who knew that a generation of youngsters
would think so very highly
of both school and their teachers we've
certainly learned to come to appreciate
them whether as students or as parents i
have to say
we've all also learnt the importance of
seeing family
and friends and going about our normal
business and hopefully we'll all
appreciate that
a lot more when the time comes even if
like alpeda you've started a new school
as we
mentioned earlier you simply can't get
to know people as well
uh from home you don't have that social
interaction um but
presumably most people are still keen to
get back and and start their education
back again
and so peter you are you still keen to
get back to school still keen to start
again doing what teenagers should be
doing
oh most definitely like we have we had
loads of plans for the summer
and hanging out with these new friends
that we wanted to go out and have
you know have food you know hang out at
parks but
it clearly wasn't meant to be and i
can't wait to go back
and just regroup as a community because
there's
the family but there's also like the
school community that we really
really need at this time and are your
parents looking forward to you going
back as well do you think
uh probably yeah that's true i can be um
well too many hours in the house with my
parents i do
it's probably enough for everybody isn't
it i think we all we all feel that too
elpida thank you very much
indeed uh yes indeed it's busy
households everywhere isn't it if you're
trying to work from home
many people of course are furloughed or
they've lost their jobs the financial
pressure is there for the whole family
and but from all of them i just want to
say a big thank you it's all we have
time for now
a very big thank you to all of you good
luck with your decisions
good luck with your work at home thank
you very much indeed for joining us
and also a big thank you to to taran
kapoor for his expertise know that
you've got lots of planning
uh for the students when they come back
should that be march the 8th or later
thank you very much indeed and thank you
for watching